julian cas de fugue et rennais
secrétaire national du parti de gauche
est responsable international des jeunes
insoumission nous avons un état corrompu
qui dort pas répondre à la rue qui est
prêt à tout pour ne pas répondre à la
rue répondent pas aux tirs et s'arrêtant
là les pieds au derrière et au nom de
cela il envoie l'armée contre les
manifestants contre sa propre population
il déclare les manifestants sont les
terroristes et donc il est en guerre
contre sa population pas c'est tout le
projet de réforme fiscale qu'il faut
retirer notamment la question de 2,2 de
la tva sur les produits de première
nécessité puisque cette tva sur les
produits première citée est extrêmement
injuste parce qu'elle va faire payer la
crise sur les personnes les plus pauvres
la société ne veut plus du rib et la
société ne veut plus il va doc et ne
veut plus de cette combi la m à l'esprit
mais certainement dans les prochaines
échéances électorales est de nouveau
dans la rue dans les années à venir ça
c'est sûr donc c'est pour ça que si on
veut le climat nouveau l'exemple de lui
en baisse alors déjà ce n'est pas envoyé
l'armée contre sa population mais en
plus c'est de trouver des accords se
faire des compromis et de voir ce qu'on
peut faire pour la justice sociale dans
le pays